so say you've done carnivore for a while
and you're trying to reintroduce Foods
how do you suggest people reintroduce
Foods so it really depends on your
current situation of why you went to
carnivore and then maybe not picking the
certain foods that have certain
anti-nutrients always start with your
Baseline and I always measure a few
markers for health it's your sleep your
mood your energies your stool and your
hormones and then use a food and mood
Journal write down everything that
you're noticing and if you let's say
want to introduce berries maybe start
with half a cup at lunch and just do one
serving and that's it and then write
down how you feel how do you feel after
an hour how's your mood how's your stool
um how's your sleep and then the next
day maybe you do half a cup at lunch and
then half a cup at dinner and so after
three to five days of using the same
food and then increasing its dosage if
you are feeling fine then that food is
probably safe for you and then you keep
doing that with every food you want to
reintroduce and if you have a bad
reaction you want to go back to Baseline
wait for that symptomology to go down
back to your Baseline and then start
with a different food and you know that
current food was not the food to
reintroduce first